and i'll get the recording going there
we go okay
um just like to welcome everybody to um
our public health engagement board and
the leader is
not available to attend today so i will
be chairing
and those that don't know me i'm
counsellor james later i'm the exec
member for health wellbeing and equality
and probably only do we have apologies
that
have been recorded that we can share
later
uh yes sir we have received apologies
from
uh obviously counter and western and
then
from uh diane eaton juan gibson
abby walsh sean donnellan
and eve mannerington
okay thank you and i was at the last
meeting and obviously the minutes of the
last meeting have been circulated so
could those be agreed
as a correct record
thank you and and i don't know i don't
know whether there are
matters arising that we need to have a
look at now or they may be i
am covered in the agenda i think i'll
leave that for elena to
guide us on that one if that's okay so
if we move on to the
um latest data and we can have an
update from eleanor thank you elena hi
okay thank you so i've sent around a
briefing on what we've
what we've been seeing this um this
week which is that we have seen
fortunately we started to see a drop in
the number of positive cases
but um in in true public health spirit
i would caution against being over
optimistic because our numbers went up
very sharply
um and we are still substantially higher
than we were at the beginning of
july so we do need to bring these
figures down and that
and and we need we need everybody's help
and this is really the purpose of this
board
is to get that engagement with our wider
community to help bring those numbers
down
um we've done really well with testing
and i'm going to ask um donna
and helen in a minute to talk a little
bit about what we're doing around
testing and contact racing
um but we still are seeing cases
across the borough we've got cases in
every ward
we're not seeing what some other areas
are seeing which is big um
multi-generational households all being
affected we're seeing
most of the household infections that
we've got ones and twos of people being
affected
you know the occasional family of maybe
three or four people
um so we're still seeing this very
widespread number of cases
um and uh we're seeing a slight increase
where we're starting to see a slight
increase is not on our youngest
population which is where we started to
see it in that 70 a youngest working age
population
in that sort of 17 to 22 year olds we're
starting now to see more cases in their
people in their 40s and 50s um
again that would be a concern because we
really don't want that that
group giving it to their parents
um and we are seeing a slight increase
in the number of cases
in um the north of the borough and quite
a few
um through the contact racing which i
think helen will talk about in a minute
a lot um various issues around some
businesses
and um transmission and some greater
manchester issues there
um in terms of
so it's a it's a um it's a good news
story
but it's um we need to really drill down
now because if we can
if we can get these numbers pushed down
now we can
it'll be really helpful for us for
getting on top of it particularly in
planning for getting schools back which
i think is one of the big things we need
to be
thinking about in this meeting donna do
you want to explain what's happening
with the testing and how
and where how we'd like the community
engagement around testing
to work yes fine so um
thanks colleagues for the opportunity to
just discuss the range of testing
opportunities we have
it's really important that the message
goes out that if anybody has any
symptoms or is concerned about potential
symptoms for kobit
that they access testing we've had a
program over the last
probably about the last month now in
trying to get testing
as close to our residents as possible
and historically we use the manchester
airport as the main key site which was
quite inaccessible for some of our
residents in the
the north of the borough so thanks to
support from colleagues at ua 92
and from bruntwood we have been able to
provide mobile testing units at the
um ua 92 site this week colleagues our
mobile testing units are at trafford
house car park which is just um the
other side of chester road
from the town hall and on wednesday
thursday friday this week we will be
back
at uh sale water park car park again
thanks to tfgm
for enabling us to use that site
um we are actively exploring
potential sites one in partington and we
have identified a school that's no
longer used
in partington mossview road school or
mossview road centre
and we are working with the department
of health to have a smaller testing unit
there
which would primarily be a walk-in
center
a walking site for residents in that
area
we're also very aware that we have
trafford park
within our borough and as you all know
that's one of our major employers
for trafford residents and also for
residents outside of trafford
and again our experience has shown that
some of the staff find it quite
difficult to access
some of the testing sites so we are
looking that we have a car park
just at the back of the trafford hotel
the old trafford hotel
which some of you may know in um in
trafford park
and again we are having a conversation
with the department of health
to see whether we could get again a
smaller probably about two to three bays
um walk-in testing opportunity there
which would enable
our employers um to use that for their
staff to be tested rapidly if there was
any
symptoms testing figures are going up as
eleanor said
and i think um the message is going out
but i'm absolutely not
convinced that it's gone out to
everybody so any support
and we've got lots of comms going out
around testing opportunities
but any support from colleagues or ideas
on how we make sure that people are
aware of testing opportunities
would be really helpful we have received
a number of very helpful videos
around testing um for our residents
who don't have english as their first
language
and those have now gone out by our
colleagues and the partnership board
to ensure again that people are aware of
the value of testing and how to access
testing sites and for those residents
who don't want to go
out or who want to stay in their
household again we can
book um tests that will be delivered to
a person's home
and they're just then the person just
needs to send those back
and again we had a major push on home
testing kits
um which saw an increase in our number
of residents who are asking for home
testing kits
so that's kind of the the structures we
have but again
really grateful colleagues for comments
on how we can continue to promote our
testing opportunities in trafford
was helen going to come in and give any
update then
or yeah thank you yeah
good morning so i'm helen collins um
dutch director of public health and
leaders the local test and trace system
just very briefly just in case you
aren't familiar with it
the test and trace system which is all
over the news this week as you'll have
seen
and the way it currently works is if you
test positive you have a positive case
ellen can you speak up a bit can you not
hear me sorry
bit quiet oh am i sorry start shouting
um so it's just
saying just a very quick update on just
so you are all aware that the current
system the way it operates
is um if somebody tests positive it goes
into the national
and trace system so that they're
referred to as tier two and tier three
they contact trace um for that
case and then if it's classed as complex
which might be
a link to a school or a particular
setting a care home
um a big kind of festival anything like
that
or a complex cohort so it might be um
our rough sleepers or people who have
experienced domestic abuse for example
then that comes into the greater
manchester system and we in trafford
work very closely with our colleagues in
the greater manchester hub
um to support the contact tracing
locally
so that's how we are today so um the
last couple of weeks has been a bit of a
roller coaster it's it's
been incredibly busy last week this week
i don't want to attempt fate but it's
looking a bit quieter in terms of our
complex settings
um but what we have really picked up on
in the last two weeks is
the impact that traffic park has on
trafford's population
so traffic park i didn't appreciate just
how big trafford park is
and also every day there's thousands of
people come into trafford park to work
and then
go home again and what we've seen is a
number of um the big workplaces have had
incidents within their workplace
settings and they might be small numbers
of trafford residents
but um you know the other cases come
from all over gm as well so it's just
recognizing the impact that trafford
park has
but i'd also say that the businesses
that we've engaged with have been really
welcoming and supporting
and and have appreciated the support
that we've given to them so that's been
really good
the things for the business public
engagement board i think that we've
very much picked upon sorry women
um have been um around
living wage populations so um about how
to support living wage populations if
they have to self-isolate
um and access to testing but also um
around
our significant workforce polished in
eastern european
um communities as well so we've been
working
with josh fulcher in the communities
team to do some
engagement with those populations
through a third sector organization
um and then the other area as well has
been smaller businesses so
these are predominantly being in the
south of the borough um but we have sent
out a blanket kind of communications out
to all workplaces
um stressing the prevention messages the
need to self-isolate and how to support
staff to test as well
so um but uh before coming onto the call
this morning we've just received an
update on how
the the system may change as well within
the next couple of weeks
and we're still waiting for more detail
on exactly what that means but there's
going to be a stronger focus on local
um contact tracing as opposed to the
national
but we'll keep you posted thanks
thanks helen thank you donna that's been
really helpful
does anybody have any questions that
they would like to ask
um eleanor obama or helen
yeah councillor walton do you want to go
first
thank you um i'm just wondering about
the uh
the um amount of positives in uh in hale
barnes i'm just wondering if there's an
explanation for that
whether it's is it the proximity of the
airport testing sites or is it something
else about hail barns do we know
so we don't know completely it does seem
to be quite widespread
um it's there's not any obvious
um groupings we've had a couple of
household outbreaks
there but um we haven't seen the large
number of the
17 to 22 year olds in that population
um i suspect
that there will be an element of um a
number of people well the the proximity
of the airport for the testing site i'm
sure is something that will
make it easier for people in hail barns
to to access it
i suspect as well but quite a lot of the
people in that community
they will be um in employment that means
they
can self-isolate at relatively low
consequence to themselves
so they may be homeworking or they may
be in jobs that are able to
um either be managed from home or where
they will get cover
um if they if they need to self-isolate
um
[Music]
we've had lots of reports about um lots
of sort of
uh bars and um restaurants and so on
being open in
in the the sort of hail and altering
them areas
um it's very hard to make any links
between
particular venues because a venue may
get named but unless actually the staff
are positive it's quite hard to work out
where somebody's picked up covet from
particularly when you're at a point
where we do think there is
you know just there is general community
transmission
so we're not sure we're trying to find
out
um it does that the numbers are at help
you know and and it may be that it is
about a willingness to engage with the
testing program
means that we're picking up cases there
that we might not be picking up
elsewhere
and i think one of the things that we'll
be looking at as we as the data
sources improve and one of the one of
the key tasks for this
um public engagement board is to try and
make
everybody across the whole of trafford
engage with testing programs
so that we can get a really good
understanding of what's happening
one of the other aspects is um we're
still
with the testing program is now opening
up more and it used to be
um i mean it still is really aimed at
people who are symptomatic
but we know quite a few asymptomatic
people are using the program and
being found to be positive even though
they have no symptoms
so i think we will be doing some studies
and joining in national studies of
what's the transmission rates between
people who are asymptomatic
rather than either pre-symptomatic or
symptomatic
but i think one of the difficulties we
have with covid is it's such a new
disease
we're still really learning all the time
about what's happening
and it's hard it's it's hard to predict
exactly
which which lines of inquiry are going
to lead somewhere
um but but the hail bonds you know that
the rates inhale bounds do appear to be
high
and continue to be high is it would it
be
is it worth bringing a testing facility
into the
into more into the community there
or in hail or somewhere i think um i
mean they there's
the community does seem to be i suppose
once we
once um and helen was talking about how
the contact tracing is changing and i
think one of the things that we'd really
want to do
once we get more resource into our
contact tracing teams
is more work with people who are testing
positive
find out what was happening and and so
on and what caused them to go for a test
and what the sorts of contacts they had
were i think as well we will be looking
at
um some work with yourselves actually
led by yourselves about are there
specific barriers to particular
population
groups about accessing testing so for
example if they if people don't have
access to a car
and how do how much does that limit it
but we also have the home testing you
offer so i we don't really want to be
having lots of little
testing offers all over the place for a
day or so at a time because it gets very
confusing for people
so i think where we do want to put where
we're putting in our local testing
service or our mobile testing
service we want to be doing it with
quite a lot of preparation beforehand
and to really make sure that we've we're
going to places where we'll pick up
a lot of people um yeah i guess i guess
there's a lot
to say any more on that sorry
there's there's a kind of a pr aspect
regarding where you put the testing
sites of course
you know because you know it causes if
you say we're putting a texting site
in a community you'll get they'll stir
up a reaction about that and oh
yeah then you know it
enables you to publicize that there may
be there is a problem in that area
but donna do you want to comment a bit
more about how we're trying to focus
because
i think it's that mix of the home
testing the online booking the car and
the walk-in services but donna you
yeah i think i think um councillor
welton makes a good point there that um
as you say there is
we have found in certain areas that
there's a challenge about if you put a
testing unit there then people feel that
prevalence is higher there than in other
areas
um i think um if you feel it's
appropriate for us to do further work
around comms around home
testing um at help in the hail barnes
area
we're really happy to do that um as i
said we've had we haven't had feedback
because it's so close to manchester
airport and because manchester airport
has lots of spaces so people rarely book
on and can't get a space
and i think most of the feedback we've
got that you know sometimes people can
book on in the morning can be tested in
the afternoon
get the results back so it's quite a
speedy service there
um and obviously um as you can be aware
gm have got a whole range of
of testing requirements and sometimes
they are
determined by a national um
uh approval process and i think because
we're so close to the airport it's quite
hard to
to identify but i think the home testing
one is something that we could do much
more
locally and promote that alongside the
airport
i'm really happy to do that council
elton
yeah sounds positive i've just got one
one suggestion
that's occurred to me um which is beer
mats
in terms of tackling you know getting
testing in people's minds when they're
you know
whether when they're out i mean i think
beer mats are fantastic for
for messaging of uh of all kinds
and i i mean as long as the as long as
the pubs will
you know will take them that i i think
you know having something like that
designed with the with with the testing
detail and
and a bit of information on them um
would be a great way of getting it
kind of into people's conscious and
subconscious while they're out enjoying
themselves
but also be a a constant reminder when
they are out enjoying themselves that
they
need to take care i dare we'll
we can pick that up with them it'll be
great if we could get some of the big
breweries to sponsor that for us
absolutely always good when somebody
else pays for it yeah
thanks for that if anybody's got any
further ideas or suggestions if they
could put them in the chat box so that
it can be picked up later because
obviously
we've just got just over half an hour
for the rest of the rest of the meeting
so
and is that if are there any further
questions around and the presentation
from eleanor donner and helen
okay george i was just going to ask
if um very positive we've seen a
reduction do we know
why that reduction is taking place in
particular be interested in what
if we can measure the impact of the
recent changes in terms of visiting
people at home and
you know so
we're trying to understand that the the
changes for
the visiting i mean if you if you assume
that the average
um infection takes five days to
come through the um you'd start
expecting to see those um
those changes having an impact um
this this week um what was interesting
though was we got quite a sharp drop on
the friday saturday and sunday
where the change is actually that
weekend we got quite a sharp drop in our
infection rates immediately
um which is far too soon to have had an
effect those people would already have
been
affected i don't know whether it's
because we did a lot of testing in that
week before and we got a lot of
publicity we got a lot of publicity on
the national news because we were
telling a slightly different story
um we had our mobile testing units in
place
already so we had good access to testing
and so i i'm hoping that it's because we
actually
did a lot of engagement in the week
before and the week before that
um but yeah i think it's still good
to say right thanks eleanor
thanks george um if we can actually now
move on to
the um ten point plan ellen is gonna
um give us some further information
around that but obviously
we want people to be involved as much as
possible and to
take pieces of work away and you know
let's have
focus groups or task and finish groups
so that we can actually
understand and work really hard and
positively during this next
six week period so um over to you
eleanor
on the um ten week plan please okay so
i'm not going to go through
every aspect of the plan in detail we've
got a ten point plan
it's ten points just because people like
ten points um we might
condense it um but i think the big ask
for us
from yourselves is that this has got to
be owned by
the people of trafford we have to have
all of our community really engaged with
this and our different communities
within trafford
because of course we're a very diverse
borough we've got lots of different
interests lots of different
sorts of people living here so i think
the ask i have for the group and in the
presentation that's gone round as well
as the plan i've just
pulled off the summary of them um
but we've got the data and intelligence
work and i really need to know from you
does the data that we produce is it
helpful to you does it
does it help you explain things to
people and what data would be helpful to
you
so that we can really make sure that the
data that we produce and i think we need
to be looking at how we put things onto
the council website
how we get things into newsletters how
we get things into stakeholder briefings
what do people want us to produce and we
will then
um design our outcomes on data
according to how it's useful for you so
i think it would be
i would find it really helpful if some
people from this group
would join us as if you like a little
bit of a data and intelligence group
for the public facing data so how we how
we do that so that's that's ask number
one
um i'll run through all the asks so if
you then um
come you know and what we can so
um counselors later i don't shall we
shall just run through the asks and then
we can
we can also we'll do an email round so
that people can
respond not immediately but um later on
as well
yeah the second ask is around the uptake
of testing and access to testing
so again it's working from some people
in this group or with wider
um groups please who would like to work
with donna
and her team on how we make sure that
testing is both
accessible to people and acceptable to
people
um and that we really get the messaging
about the importance of testing out
people i think coupled with that is um
the assistance we need around contact
tracing and really selling the message
of the importance of contact racing
and again working with helen and the
contact racing team and environmental
health
on how we how we make sure that people
are able to
engage with that contact racing the next
bit is about those community engagement
plans and that's really
i mean that's the summary of all of the
work of this group will be about how do
we have a really clear program of
activities
there's a rolling program it with the
action plan that we've put together is
really for
old august and september what we'll be
doing is
um putting together time limited actions
evaluating how those worked and then
reviewing the plan sort of fit four
weekly so
monthly so that we have a constant um
six week plan a rolling program
but really it is about looking at the
specific community engagement work that
we can do
and how how you can support us with that
and
and amplify our communications messages
there's a section on the plan about
engagement with the hospitality sector
and with businesses
and with events and how we support
people around events to make
things over secure
another big piece that i think is very
much the bread and butter of this group
is the
support to residents and patients who
are clinically vulnerable
higher risk populations and how we
support them with shielding
but also how we support those people who
self-isolation will mean um severe
income drops and where we how we manage
to make sure that we can get
um people linked into
other support if they are having to self
isolate and if they're on a low income
so i think that is an absolutely
critical role for this group because
what we're starting to see not so much
in trafford but certainly in some other
areas
is people not engaging with the contact
racing process because they don't want
to give names of people who they know
will suffer financially
if they have to self-isolate so it's
about what is the offer for trafford how
do we explain that offer
for people and how do we support people
so that they are able to self-isolate
um there's a general point around the
infection control
and again the messaging about how to
stay safe
the big piece of work that i would
really
really value your assistance with and i
know helen and karen samples
in from the education lead would really
value your help with
is how do we um how do we engage with
parents and teachers particularly
parents about
making the school return safe because we
have got to get our children back into
school that is absolutely essential
but we have to do it safely and i think
we probably need to be
you know anything you can do to support
us linking into parents
so that we can start addressing their
concerns early
now over the next couple of weeks before
they're
having to make the decisions about
children going back to school
and i suggest with that that's probably
three different groups
of um work plans one will be the primary
schools in early years
one is for secondary schools and the
final is the sixth form colleges
um but really anything you can do to
support us
with getting both the messages we want
to get out but also so that we can hear
what the concerns are and really get
good plans together to address them
um and the final one is we'll be
producing a list of the
interventions that will have the biggest
impact on containing the spread of covid
um and that will be the pieces of work
that we'll be wanting to talk to you
about
if our rates start to go up again
dramatically or if they
start to go up in any particular combat
um populations
we'll want to be talking to you about
what are the effective interventions and
how can you
support us in making sure those inter in
interventions
are implemented effectively because i
think what we want to do
is try and manage this without ending up
in further lockdown
so the more we can do with getting
people to understand what's in their own
power
and how we address how we manage and
cover dress ourselves
the better so but it really is this is
an enormous
ask of all of you to support us
thank you and it's a
very detailed action plan and thanks
thank you and your team for putting it
together and
other comments and questions or do
people want to say if they want to be
involved
at this point do we want to have a
discussion around what that would look
like
and happy to take questions and comments
at this point
hi can you hear me sandy from
healthwatch
hi andy hi i just wanted to check
um some of the things you've been
talking about we're happy to be involved
in anything
any sub groups and discussions that
would be relevant um but i'm just
thinking that
in some of those it might be some of our
members of staff that would be more
appropriate to
be involved in those discussions
yeah that would be really helpful andy i
think that if you could
let eleanor and her team know who those
members of staff are then uh obviously
who can make contact so i just wanted to
check whether
that was no that's fine yeah yeah yeah
if you want to
do something with your team and then
tell us who who it's going to be that'll
be absolutely fantastic thank you
no that's fine if you're going to send
an email around with the action points
after this then we can look at that and
then we can decide who's
who's best suited for it yeah no problem
thank you so much
is there anybody else who thinks that
they would be able to support some of
the work
and to take away because obviously we as
a
borough have to do this together you
know the council can't just do this on
its own and tell people
what it's expecting them to do it needs
to be led by
and people from the community and and
other services
so that we can actually you know get get
what we need delivered because
like eleanor said i think one of the
most important things for us going
forward at the minute is
opening education and in september and
opening it safely
and obviously keeping our um older
population
and it's safe and safe and well as well
so if there's anybody else
george you're muted to speak thank you
only to say i think the plan is really
good and it's really
you know thorough and quite specific i'd
be happy to help i'll look in a bit more
detail and get back to
donna elena and helen around
where they might be able to help i
started dorothy african caribbean care
group yeah i'm really pleased with the
plan
um really would love to get engaged and
support and support
it but when like george has a bit more
detail
as to how we can um support then uh that
will be helpful we'll get back to you on
that
thank you dorothy that's really helpful
and
if people once the email goes out and
with the details and then people can
respond to that and it'd be really
helpful if for the next meeting we could
have
sort of like we know we know who's doing
what i think we're meeting again in two
weeks so i think that if we've got
something started some
and groups already set up and running
that would be really helpful because
you know time time is of the essence
with the covid we haven't got um you
know
we need to we need to do as much as we
possibly can to
to prevent us having to go into any kind
of lockdown
and that's happened in in some of our
neighbouring borders so
um any comments or
suggestions i'm happy to take those now
or we can just move on
i think the um what would i'd really
like this to do
is to really help us understand how we
get
community engagement embedded in our
service design
so around covid but more generally this
should be a really good vehicle for
helping us understand how we get more of
a
community voice into all the things we
do so
this should be seen as a um
a practice run if you like for for that
wider
for wider community engagement with all
of services because
i think what one of the things that
covet is teaching us isn't it
is that um it's it's the biggest impact
is in our lowest income populations it's
on our most vulnerable populations
and it is about how do we help get a
voice to those people
so that we end up with the people living
in the housing that they need that the
quality of services improves generally
across the board but particularly in
areas where we know we're seeing the
worst health impacts the people who
having the worst health impacts are the
people who
have the worst health impacts more
generally so it is about how we
how we get those voices heard so that we
can make sure that
all of the things that make them more
vulnerable get addressed
just had a quick look at the chat and
some people have been putting in and
comments that are really helpful and
people saying that they'd like to be
involved more so that's brilliant
did you want to come back in yeah it's
just about safe just picking up on what
ellen has
said there we've got the um recovery
plan communication engagement meeting
tomorrow and i think it'll be important
to take
this and to get some feedback there and
also we've talked about the community
response hubs in their role i think
we've got a meeting tomorrow
again it's to talk about how we can
support the
communications through the response hubs
so we'll be able to feed that back at
the next meeting
from both those groups george
um councillor walton do you want to come
back in
thank you um i'm just wondering is have
any thoughts being given to
sort of creating some kind of media
panel
um so that we you know so that we know
that we
to help the organ you know the the the
media outlets that we have
particularly the online ones such as i
mean locally to me it would be altering
him today
but you know educating the the you know
the people who are who are editing and
and running those platforms and and
maybe you know
briefing them and and giving them an
indication of the kind of
the kind of work that they could do to
that would be helpful
rather than you know maybe some of the
more sensationalist stories that we get
you know seeing we can work with those
those outlets to
to get them into a more of a helpful
frame of uh frame of reference
but obviously the we do have some
community newspapers as well but
increasingly people are getting their
messages online
community facebook groups and that kind
of thing so if we could identify
some of the you know the key players in
those
and bring them together maybe we can we
can
that could be helpful can i make a
suggestion
um and and i think sometimes a video is
even all be very very short can be quite
powerful
and they are usually shared across all
platforms of social media
so i was on a group
meeting last friday and we had the um
the director of public health for
sulfadon and she was speaking directly
to
a community audience who engaged with
the message
now that might be an opportunity uh for
yourself eleanor
um to perhaps maybe have a film
maybe very very short with with the
message that we can share
um directly coming from yourself and we
could share that
um across our various um social media
platforms
i think that's that i'm very happy to do
that and i think it'd be great as well
if we could have some
different voices so perhaps some of the
younger people and so on if we could get
some
some and different populations giving
the messages as well so i think if we
can have
maybe even a montage of videos or so on
of people
people giving those messages and um
trying to encourage people
because we do know that social media is
absolutely vital for a lot of this
so with the contact tracing again one of
the pieces we've had
feedback we've had from some areas is
people are not giving their names to the
contact tracers but they are assuring
the contact tracers that they've been
linking in with people through social
media um
now if if that then translates into
those people
getting tested and self-isolating and so
on actually
that is a really good piece of work done
but we do need to make sure we've got
that quality within the social media
that people understand
what the implications of the positive
tests are or of being a contact
are so yeah very keen to do that
right thanks thanks did you want to come
in and
tell marvel do you want to come in
do you want to come in
social media is very very important uh
one of the reasons is well i'm a member
of many
platforms the problem is people are
getting these
horror stories from across the world and
from many other countries and people are
getting very depressed by
seeing those so i think we got a role to
play to
bring the reality of our local reality
to our local people
i think that's that's a very hard task
but that is something which we have to
tackle
otherwise we are bombarded with a lot of
information from the us
and president trump and people like that
and does not actually give people a lot
of confidence
totally agree we need to be getting our
own message out
and with you know with our evidence to
back it up instead of people
filling and void themselves with
some rubbish that's online so that's
really really helpful
and obviously we can we can have a look
at that i think that's a really good
suggestion
and is it is that the end of comments on
this
point or does anybody else want to say
anything
i think i think we have got i think
picking up carl mogul's point
it is that issue of some people are
absolutely terrified
and are really becoming ill because they
are so worried about kobit
and it's having a huge impact on their
mental and physical health and then
we've got another group of people who
think it doesn't have any implications
for them at all
and it's really trying to get that
balance between you know
is a serious disease it can be a very
very serious disease
equally for a lot of people it's a very
mild disease and it's a very
it's a very confusing and difficult
message i think at the moment for people
um so it the more we can get to help
people
get it into proportion but and and to
provide the
and understand what they can do to
protect themselves the better i think
thanks eleanor and i think that sort of
like covers the
10-point plan and thanks for everybody
who sort of put suggestions forward and
they're going to look to
help us further with that and if we can
move on
i think we're going to have a discussion
now around the priorities action
and actions for the board going forward
so over
to eleanor i think
i mean to be fair i think um
the the the two things are very much
covered i think
um i know i suppose it's about how do we
um two questions for the board one is
by being on the board and there's quite
a few people i know who couldn't make it
today
but i really want us to be um able to
pull on your assistance
to move things forward so what uh what
we'll be doing i think after this
i haven't heard anyone say that the plan
things on the plan don't feel like the
right things
so um obviously there's a huge urgency
around the school's work
there's a huge urgency i think as well
about the general support that we need
for helen and donna around the contact
racing and how we get
if you'd like some expert reference
groups set up for that
um the data side as well i could really
do with some conversations with people
about
is the data accessible to people is it
making sense are the messaging you know
can't
or you know how do we put a narrative
around that data
that helps people um but i it feels to
me like the big pieces of work from this
now
are how do we use this work and our
comms plan
and engagement plan for the covered work
the link into the other pieces of work
for example with the lco
um so this is very much part of an
overall communication strategy and
engagement strategy
with the local care organization for
health and social care for trafford
which i know tracy and george are very
close to
and and jamie and we'll be able to talk
a little bit more about
how that those um
means can be used to help spread the
message
but i think the main thing i really
wanted to get from from this group today
is your commitment to the the
action plan and your commitment to
supporting us with that
and to directing it and making sure that
it has an action plan
that you want to front as trafford
residents
it's got to be our plan it's not my plan
thanks elena i think council walter
wants to come back in
yeah i'm interested in the the point
about education
because i mean as a as a parent you know
i
might this two schools that my kids go
to
have provided extensive sort of
information about what the school is
going to be like
when they go back and are doing a lot
you know you
seem to be doing quite a lot of work to
you know to reassure parents and that
kind of thing
i'm just a bit concerned that we could
end up
we're trying to reinvent that wheel and
duplicate that process i'm not certain
exactly
what more can be done given that schools
are such strong structures with
strong such strong cons with the parents
in their own right
what more can we add to that
helen i don't know if you want to
comment on that but i think it's really
just making sure that
we're supporting the schools and the
head teachers with those comms and
making sure that they
i think it's it's what will resonate
with parents so if you're hearing
messages from
parents about what their concerns are
can you feed those back
up to us because we're already engaging
with the schools and with the education
teams about that but sometimes we can be
thinking that parents have a worry about
one thing
and trying to address that worry and
actually you can make things worse
because that might not have been their
worry at all they might be worried about
something completely different
so it's really just to get that voice of
the parent
through which of course they are giving
through the schools
and of course the school the schools
have been doing fabulous work all the
way through this and this is not
at all a criticism of any of the work
the schools have been doing
but it's really about trying to make
sure that we're we're able to support
the schools with getting children back
in
and support parents to feel safe helen
did you want to
yeah so um just to echo what eleanor
said and it's really
positive counselor welton to hear that
your schools that your kids go to
are really engaged in getting them back
in i think there's a
balance isn't there between uh
protecting children from
covid and protecting children's
well-being and education as well and
we need to get them back into school as
a parent myself i'm desperate for my
children to go back into school i have
to say
but um what i would say as well is to
many people on this call
i appreciate that many of you will have
a role as a governor as well in a school
so it's just about supporting your
leadership teams through this because
it's very it's been i'm a governor as
well
um and it's been a very difficult time
for our heads and our
senior leaders in school so it's just
about supporting the school ensuring
that they're linked in with us
um in the public health team to provide
any support
but we do have really good strong
relationships with our head teachers
from um the majority of our schools in
trafford so
yeah so any kind of support or feedback
you can provide back to us
would be really appreciated and then
also um
just supporting the leadership teams of
your school as well
thanks helen i think the point about us
a lot of people on this call will be and
school governors i'm school governor in
the world that i
um cover and the school has been you
know
really proactive and throughout the
whole um
lockdown process you know shared
information with parents that you know
done weekly letters to parents to keep
them
to keep them engaged and so that you
don't feel safe and confident in
and sending the children to school so i
do think you know
i'm a parent but my kids are criminal
but you know
as as parents of children who are
attending school i think that
you know if we can engage as best as we
can and with schools but
also as as local authority and governors
i think we need to you know we do have
responsibilities to be engaging with our
schools and understanding
what we're doing in our local area so
that's that's great hello thanks very
much
and if we can now move on and report for
the health and well-being board
oh no it's over to you again thank you
so much
so i suppose and we've got the health
and wellbeing board on friday
and so we'll be producing a report from
this board into the health and wellbeing
board
um my proposal is that we will be
summarizing the discussion we've had
today
and if i am the meetings on friday
and i would really like to be able to go
to that board saying we've established
subgroups to support us with the work
and to lead some of the work so you will
be getting an email after today
or today um asking for volunteers and so
on so that i can feed that back into the
health and wellbeing board
and also obviously what we'll be trying
to do and laura's on the call
as well who is going to be leading on
the program management for this board
and the health protection board
so that she will be starting to put
together some with yourselves
um some actual uh time limited actions
that people are going to do
so that we can make sure that we're able
to monitor the progress that we're
making and the engagement we're
achieving
through this board and that we can try
and make sure that we have
some idea of the impact of this board
because i do think that
you know when we're asking the question
about what's happening individual wards
and so on
um we would want to be able to come back
and say well actually we've got people
on the case
and they are doing some face-to-face or
they have done some community engagement
or this is what we're hearing from our
counsellors this is what we're hearing
from our voluntary sector groups
so that we can feed that back in see
what's working
and um and really learn from that
that's on that well we've come to the
end of the agenda and so
let's thank everybody for attending i
think there's some good points that have
been raised
and in the chat that um obviously the
officers will take away and use as part
of this process
so all be prepared for your volunteering
email from eleanor after this call and
thanks and everybody thanks for being
patient with me
uh sharing this meeting and while
funding is not available so
thank you everybody and hello through
you through your video
just quickly can we please um
mention to board members and and other
participants
the next meeting is on the 25th
of august at 10 o'clock already
circulated list of
future dates and however i will do it
again
as soon as we um circulate this meaning
but the next one is on the 25th of
august at
10 o'clock thank you thank you fabiola
so
25th of august at 10 o'clock you should
i'll be able to resume normal
and practices because i won't be around
but thank you very much everybody
bye thank you bye
bye